in desperation a couple whose son has
laid in a vegetative state for years
adopts a sophisticated robot in the form
of a child
one capable of love today on sin we
recapped i'll show you ai artificial
intelligence
the film begins with the owner of a
company who says that robots have
evolved and he shows an example using a
robot woman who even responds to pain
the man tells the other attendees that
he wants to create a new robot a child
capable of loving his adoptive parents
they begin to wonder how they're going
to be able to make that possible three
months pass and we see a couple going to
visit their son who's in the hospital
there they keep him alive by means of
machines since he has a rare disease one
of the doctors tells the man that the
woman has not been able to accept the
loss of her son because she still has
hope he'll be cured even knowing that
many years have passed then the man
comes up with the idea of taking a
robotic child to his wife so they can
replace his son although this robot is
still a test and is the only one of its
kind the woman named monica at first
gets very angry with her husband telling
him that this robotic child cannot
replace her biological son however that
night she sees the robot in more detail
and begins to think about whether she
should adopt him or not the next day the
husband henry tells his wife that they
gave him the robot child in the factory
where he works
and that they explain to him if they
really want to adopt they must say
certain words in a certain order so the
child's system is activated then the
child can start loving monica as if she
were his mother he also explains that
this mechanism can only be activated
once there will be no going back this
means that the robot child can only love
one pair of parents so in the event that
the parents no longer love the child
they can't sell it so they'll have to
send it back to the factory where he
would be destroyed henry tells his wife
to think carefully about whether or not
she wants to adopt the child because
after activating it there will be no
turning back and that she also has to
sign a contract monica replies that
she's not sure and that she's going to
think about it a little more monica
spends the day with the child although
she feels very uncomfortable because the
robot is very curious and follows her
everywhere but he also makes her laugh
the next day monica decides to activate
the child by saying the words that were
indicated in the manual after
pronouncing them the boy named david
says mommy to monica and she hugs him
very happily a few days go by and the
cup was about to go out when suddenly
the boy asks monica if one day she is
going to die to which she replies yes
then the boy tells her that he will be
very sad so monica decides to give david
a toy she gives him a moving stuffed
animal called teddy and tells them to
take care of each other some time later
monica receives a call and the hospital
tells her that her biological son martin
is cured that he can return home so they
take him home and introduce him to the
robot boy martin and the robot boy begin
to live together but martin treats david
as if he were a toy and not like his
brother meanwhile monica treats martin
like a child to whom she reads stories
and she makes david do the homework one
day the family is eating when suddenly
martin starts bragging to david that he
can eat food because david only pretends
that he eats even though there's nothing
on his plate at that moment the robot
boy decides to eat real food but this
causes him to break down and they have
to take him to be repaired martin urges
david to cut a lock of monica's hair
telling that this way she'll love him
more david takes a pair of scissors and
cuts a lock of her hair but he's later
caught by the parents the man gets very
angry with david and starts to shake him
because he thinks he wanted to hurt
monica and causes the lock of hair to
fall out however the stuffed animal that
was also there takes that lock and keeps
it for himself the next day henry tells
monica that they should return david to
the factory because he's a danger to the
family but monica forbids him to do so
because she knows that if they take him
away you'll be destroyed
then one of martin's friends tries to
hurt david to see if he responds to pain
which causes david to get scared so he
clings to his brother martin to take
care of him and the two end up falling
in the water the father throws himself
into the water to separate the robot
from martin because david's metal body
made the two sink to the bottom of the
pool henry takes his son out and then
takes him to the hospital while the
robot boy is left at the bottom of the
pool due to all this monica decides to
take david back to the factory but on
the way she regrets it and takes him to
a forest to leave him there the robot
boy begs her not to leave him alone but
monica still ends up abandoning him that
night david was walking aimlessly
through the woods when suddenly a group
of people who went to robots without
family to destroy them start chasing him
until they catch him although the
stuffed animal manages to escape the
teddy bear arrives at a fair where
someone takes it through the room of
lost objects since they say that it's a
toy that has no owner then we see that
in that fair they use the robots they
capture to have fun because they put
them in a cannon to destroy them the
teddy bear manages to escape from the
room of lost objects but then it's found
by a girl who's the daughter of the man
who controls the bear the teddy bear
tells the girl that they have david
locked up and she goes to tell her dad
the man goes to look for david in the
cage because he believes that he's a
real child however when he examines him
he realizes that he's a robot which is
strange to him since there are currently
no robot children even so the man
decides to take david to burn him in
front of everyone but david begins to
beg for his life something that
apparently robots do not usually do
so everyone begins to protest that they
shouldn't burn him and among all the
chaos david and the teddy bear managed
to escape along with another robot david
decides to go in search of a fairy
because he read in the story of
pinocchio that she could turn him into a
real boy and he hopes that monica will
love him if he was a real boy the other
robot tells him that he knows where that
fairy could be
so david decides to follow him
they reach a city and go to consult a
doctor who's an artificial intelligence
as well and asks him where he can find
the fairy the doctor tells him that they
must go to the end of the world where
they can find a doctor who knows how to
turn robots into humans the robot warns
david that if he goes to that place he
may never return but david tells him
that even so he wants to go because he
really wants monica's love the robot
tells him that monica will never love
him because he's just a robot and that
if she abandoned him it was because
she'd gotten tired of him but david
still decides to continue with the plan
then david and the robot take a
helicopter from some men and travel to
the end of the world when they arrive
they find collapsed buildings and
everything full of water david the other
robot and the teddy bear see everything
through the window and arrive at a
building looking for the doctor when
david enters he finds a robot just like
him and he goes crazy because he thinks
he's going to take monica away from him
so he destroys the copy the robot that
accompanied him gets scared and runs
away taking the teddy bear with him at
that moment the doctor appears and david
asks him if he knows where to find the
fairy the doctor tells him that he does
not need to look for the fairy because
he's already real since david is able to
embark on a journey with a goal which
other robots cannot do david is
surprised and the doctor asks him if he
wants to meet his real parents and all
the team who built him david goes to see
the facilities and realizes that there
are many robots just like him then he
grows very sad because he thought he was
unique so he decides to jump into the
water from very high up and descend to
the bottom of the sea along with other
waste just then his robot friend arrives
and takes him out of the water with a
submarine once he's ashore david tells
him that he saw where the fairy lives
but he saw her at the bottom of the sea
however at that moment a magnet takes
the robot away
leaving david alone then david and the
teddy bear decide to use the submarine
to go to the bottom of the water and
look for the ferry after much searching
they find figures that represent the
story to pinocchio they follow the path
until they find a statue of the ferry at
which point a ferris wheel fails causing
them to get trapped but david still
focuses on the ferry and astrid and
turning into a real boy
we see that david keeps begging day
after day even after the submarine
lights die and the sea freezes
he keeps begging and begging to be made
into a real boy until two thousand years
have passed then we see some strange
beings land in the frozen waste they
stop right in front of where david was
trapped and they find the frozen body of
the robot boy and the teddy bear these
aliens touch him and david wakes up to
see the fairy again
he gets out of the submarine and
approaches to see the statue of the
fairy meanwhile the aliens talk amongst
each other saying that david probably
has information about what humans were
like and at that moment david touches
the statue causing it to collapse an
alien approaches david and collects the
information he has based on his memories
and passes this information to all his
other companions memories then come to
david and he feels at home so he starts
yelling at his mom and ends up finding
the fairy david asks the fairy again for
his wish but the fairy tells him that
she can't do that however we soon see
that everything is part of the
simulation that the aliens are running
they make david see through the fairy
that two thousand years have passed and
that his mother can no longer return
they also explain that they can bring
back deceased people but that they need
a dna test at that moment the teddy bear
tells david that he still has the lock
of his mother's hair the david cut and
gives it to him david gives the lock to
the fairy and at that moment an alien
enters the room to talk to david he
explains that they were very interested
in meeting humans so they began to
create a method recreated and seized
people from their dna unfortunately the
alien tells them that the experiment
failed since resurrected people only
lived for one day so it's practically
impossible to bring david's mother back
to life and if they did they'd warn him
that he can only see her for one day and
then never again david says that it
doesn't matter that maybe monica is
special and can stay longer so the
aliens grant his wish and bring monica
back to life
david gets a chance to see his mother
again and makes her coffee they spend
time talking and monica is confused
about what day it is she also seems not
to remember her husband or her
biological son then david and monica
begin to have a good time together they
brush each other's hair
david tells her all the adventures he
lived in search of the fairy they play
hide and seek they bake a cake since
david had never had a birthday party
then it gets dark and david takes his
mother to bed she tells him that she
loves him very much and david cries with
happiness because he heard what he
wanted so much that his mother loved him
monica falls asleep forever and david
lies down next to her although robots
are not supposed to sleep david manages
to fall asleep next to her the end
if you liked the video please leave a
like and subscribe to continue receiving
the recaps of the best sci-fi and drama
movies thanks for watching